Sophia Vergara and Joe Manganiello  honeymoon and style and et has the  romantic new pics Sophia and Joe were  snapped boarding a private plane to  Turks and Caicos following their  star-studded nuptials last week the  newlyweds dressed casually for their  travels but of course a plain white tee  and jeans didn't stop Sophia from still  looking glamorous Modern Family star  also flashed a big smile clearly a  glowing newlywed and check out a view of  their stunning destination Sophia and  Joe stayed at parrot K a swanky private  island resort a source tells et quote  they have the biggest private pool in  the resort  it appears the couple enjoyed a romantic  week in after a huge storm interrupted  their vacay still an eye witness tells  et that the pair was happy and smiling  when they were spotted out and looked  very much in love